i mean maybe one way to talk about that
is
people know about the drake equation
which is
a very high level almost framework to
think about
what is the probability that correct me
if i'm wrong
that there's life out there and
intelligent life i think i don't know
but then the
equation named after you now which
i think nicely focuses in on the more
achievable and interesting uh part of
that
question which is on whether there is
habitable
planets out there or how many i guess
right
so the funny thing is was one time i met
frank drake
and i asked if he minded if i took his
equation and kind of
revamped it for this new field of
exoplanet astronomy
he was totally cool with it he's he got
total approval well maybe uh
okay so i'm not sure if he'd actually
read the stuff about my equation but he
was cool with it he was cool with it
uh okay so i just said like 15 different
things but
maybe can you tell from your perspective
what is the drake equation
and what is sorry the seeger equation
sure well the drake equation as you said
it's a framework
it's a description of the number of
civilizations out there
of intelligent beings that are able to
communicate with us by radio waves so if
you think of like the mu if you think of
the movie contact you've seen contact
right
we're hoping to get as we're listening
in actually it's an active field of
research
listening to other stars at radio
wavelengths hoping that some
intelligent civilizations are sending us
a message and the drake equation
came like at the start of that whole
field to put the factors down on paper
to sort of illustrate what is involved
to kind of estimating and there's no
real estimate or a prediction of how
many civilizations are out there
but it's a way to frame the question and
show you each term that's involved
so i took the drake equation and i
called it a revised drake equation
and i recast it for the search for
planets
by more traditional astronomy means
we're looking at stars looking for
planets looking for rocky planets
looking for planets that are the right
temperature for life
looking for planets that might have life
that outputs gases that we might detect
in the future
it's the same spirit of the drake
equation it's not going to give us any
magic numbers
so i'm going to say hey here's exactly
what's out there it's meant to kind of
guide
guide of where we're going although the
jerk equation did i mean the initial
equation proposed actual numbers for
those variables
oh yes the equation proposed numbers and
you can still
plug your own numbers in and there's
this really cute website that lets you
for both the drake and my revised
equation plug in some numbers and see
what you get
so yeah so okay so what are what are
i mean what are the variables but maybe
also what are like the critical
variables so in my equation i set out to
what are the numbers of
inhabited planets that show signs of
life by way of gases in the atmosphere
that can be attributed to life
i could just walk through the terms
that's similar the first thing i say is
what are the number of stars available
and it's not that those trillions and
trillions of stars everywhere
it's what are available to like a
specific search
and so for example the mit led nasa
mission tess
is surveying the sky looking for all
kinds of planets but it can also
it also has stars it has about 30 000
red dwarf stars
so we just take a number of stars that a
given survey can access
so that's what the number of stars is
then i wanted to know what kind of stars
are
uh quiet a quiet i called it
a fraction of those stars that is quiet
in the case of tess the way it's looking
for planets
is planets that transit the star they go
in front of the star as seen from the
telescope
but it turns out that some stars are
very active they're variable
and they brighten and dim with time and
that interferes with our observation
i apologize to interrupt so it's a
transiting planet so you're
really looking for a black blob
essentially that blocks the light
we're looking for a black blob that
blocks light and then trying to say
something about the size of the planet
uh from the frequency of that black
blobs appearance and the size of that
black blob that kind of thing yeah but
let's just say that
out of all the stars there are
accessible to whatever telescope some of
them are just bad
for whatever reason you're not gonna be
able to find planets around them
so i need to know the fraction of those
that are that are good so again we have
the number of stars the fraction of them
that we can actually find planets around
um and by the way is our sun that one
such
is is our sun quiet our sun is quiet
okay
so i have actually two terms one
describes how quiet they are and one is
if we can find a planet around that star
these transiting planets for example
not all planets transit because the
planet would have to be orbiting that
star
in this kind of plane as viewed from you
but if a star is for example orbiting in
the plane of the sky it will never
transit
it will never go in front of the star so
in that case we have to have a fraction
that
takes into account that kind of
geometric
factor and hopefully it's right i mean
you can assume that it's uniformly
distributed hopefully yes we can assume
and there's evidence that it's uniformly
distributed yes
so then the next so all of these factors
so far
number of stars accessible to whatever
telescope you're thinking about
how many stars are quiet fraction stars
that are quiet fraction
that are observable in this case for the
geometric factor
those are all things we can measure and
there's one more term in the seeger
equation we can measure
i call it fraction of planets in the
habitable zone
because believe it or not we have a
handle on that for a
certain set of stars we know from our
the kepler space telescope that operated
for a number of years
we have estimates for how many planets
are in the so-called habitable zone of
the host star for a certain type of star
so all those we have measurable and then
like the drake equation itself there are
some terms we can
not measure and those ones i call them
fl
fraction of all those planets that have
life on them
because we don't know what that is and
fs i called for spectroscopy
the fraction that have we can use our
telescope and instrument tools to
look for light actually fs was the ones
that the planets that
that have life that actually gives off a
gas a useful gas that might accumulate
in the atmosphere
so we could eventually observe it uh
how do the fl and fs interplay so these
are separate terms
separate terms and so so for example
you could imagine so for example you
could imagine life
like us humans we breathe out carbon
dioxide
but our planet earth we already have a
lot of carbon dioxide on it
well we have hundreds of parts per
million but it has a really strong
signal
so us humans breathing out carbon
dioxide it's not helpful for any
intelligent beings that are looking back
at earth
because there's already a lot of there's
already enough carbon dioxide we're not
adding to it
so if there is life on a planet and it's
outputting a boring gas that's not
helpful for us to uniquely
identify as being made by life versus
just being there anyway
then it's not helpful so i separated
those two terms out
soon i think we'll have evidence that
planets that can support life
at least are common so
okay this is such an awesome topic i
have a million questions uh
what okay i know it's a little bit of
speculation but what's your sense about
that
uh i think fs which is like
that uh life would produce
interesting gases that would be able to
detect like is there
one is there scientific evidence and and
second is there some intuition around
life producing gases with detectable
hints in terms of
chemistry so interestingly enough that
entire question
relates to i'm going to say almost my
life's work yeah the work i'm doing now
and the work i'm doing for the next 20
years
and i wish i could give you a concrete
number like one percent like on
the worst days it's one percent let's
say in my mind
you know in the best days it's like 80
and i could actually go into
a lot of detail here but i'll just give
you the simplest things
so first of all we make an assumption
that like us
and our life here on earth life uses
chemistry
so we use chemistry because we eat food
we breathe air and we have metabolism
that
to break down food to get energy to
store energy
and then ultimately to use it and all
life here has some kind of byproduct in
in doing all that some kind of waste
product that goes into the atmosphere
so i like to think that life everywhere
uses chemistry
some people have imagined like uh let's
imagine like a windmill like mechanical
energy
just getting energy and using it without
storing it and if there was life like
that it might not need to output a gas
so we make this basic assumption of
chemistry that's the first thing
the second more complicated thing that i
and my team work on is what happens to
the gas once it is
produced by life it goes into the
atmosphere and a lot of gas
is just destroyed immediately actually
by ultraviolet radiation
or by oxygen oxygen's incredibly
destructive to a lot of gases so the gas
can be produced by life but it could be
just completely destroyed by its
environment
i guess we should pause on that that
you mentioned your life's work i mean
this is just a beautiful idea
that uh it's kind of paralyzing when you
look out there and you wonder is there a
life out there
is it's the first paralyzing actually
before i encountered your work i feel
like an idiot
but you know uh it feels like there's no
tool to answer that question
and then what you kind of provided
is this cool idea that it might be
possible to answer that by looking at
the gases i mean that's a really
interesting that's a beautiful idea
and uh yeah so we could just pause on
like yeah
that's as a powerful tool i think
that uh to build the intuition around
because i was totally clueless about it
and that was kind
it's kind of exciting i mean i'm sure
there's a folks
probably early on in your life uh who
were very skeptical about this notion
maybe i'm not sure but it's generally
you would want to be skeptical it's like
well
uh all these kinds of other things could
generate gases
you know all those oh that's so true and
that's a big part of this
growing field is how to make sure that
this gas isn't produced by another
effect
but i do want to you know again pausing
on that and going back a bit
it's incredible to think but like at
least almost 100 years ago
there's a record of someone talking
about the idea of a gas being an
indicator of life elsewhere
oh that
and it comes down to oxygen which on our
planet fills our atmosphere
to 20 by volume and you know we rely on
oxygen to breathe
you know when they you hear about the
people on mount everest running out of
air
they're really running out of oxygen
well they're running out of oxygen
because the air is getting thinner
as you they climb up the mountain but
without plants and bacteria there's
plants that
bacteria that also photosynthesizes and
produces oxygen as a waste product
without those we would have virtually no
oxygen
our atmosphere would be devoid of oxygen
so yeah what uh if you were to analyze
uh earth is oxygen the strong indicator
here oxygen is a huge indicator and
that's what we're hoping that there is
an intelligent civilization
not too far from here around a planet
orbiting a nearby tsar
with the kind of telescopes we're trying
to build and they're looking back at our
sun and they've seen our earth and they
see oxygen and they
they probably won't be like 100.00 sure
that there's life making it
but if they go through all the possible
scenarios they'll be left with a pretty
strong hint
that there's life here
you